Brian it's always dangerous to drink
before noon especially on a weekday but
that's what we're going to do tell me
how to beat the price squeeze on limes
first of all happy cinco tomorrow like I
ain't no la feliz cinco de mayo yes and
all the people don't know but it's your
birthday too it is my birthday it's a
happy birthday all of North American is
complaining celebrating my birthday cuz
you know Americans drink over a hundred
and eighty-five thousand margaritas per
hour in this country what FYI in case
you didn't know so we're gonna start off
in order to beat the the long 24 hours a
day oh yeah I was reading earlier Las
Vegas do you know that lime juice is now
more expensive per ounce than most
achelous crazy wow it's so water being
more expensive than gasoline a little
bit so we're gonna take some
fresh-squeezed of course fresh-squeezed
grapefruit juice and rue this is the
replacement yes Andrew be written in
season right now so it actually can get
if you want if you want to avoid the the
Mexican a citrus which is so expensive
right now you can get florals in
California or even Texas is now doing
great citrus we're now of course add a
little bit of Cointreau which is what we
find in a traditional margarita which is
little orange liqueur made with sugar
beet it's also forty percent alcohol by
volume and then we're gonna add some
Highland tequila one hundred percent
agave tequila and this one's from the
highlands of Jalisco Mexico what's the
difference between tequila and mezcal
well basically birthday from agave and
tequila like it's a cactus like plant
right yeah it looks like that this is a
from club soda okay club soda on top
final ingredient and final ingredient
and you know a lot of people use the
agave plant it looks like it's like I
never cross between oh I would say it's
like a distant cousin to aloe vera okay
okay and it's not an actual cactus a lot
of people think it is and then the
difference ring tequila and mezcal they
actually smoked the agave says release
yeah it has a smoky flavor and that's
the one has the worm in it you'll never
find a worm in a bottle of tequila never
has been never will be yeah so can pick
that up and give it two days yeah it's
just tequila ice cube Cointreau on the
way but pub soda and we gonna do this
I'll give it your finger lose it doesn't
work that is a sexy ice cube all right
uh it interferes with the drinking it
does that is great but it looks very
cool shortage of limes no problem all
right what's next well next gonna do a
riff on the classic margarita and said
we're gonna use fresh squeezed lime
juice okay of course it's a me going up
market now with lines yeah I'm in a
classic margarita you know it was
invented by Mark Margaret Sam's around
1948 and she was a text of socialite who
was down to Al Capone she's some fresh
squeezed lime juice some Cointreau
triple sec and then she used some
tequila right she made this cocktail and
voila and voila so what we're going to
do is the same cocktail with I've
already assembled ingredients but what
we're going to do to this one is we're
going to add a little bit of cilantro
nice classic like I'm saying you want to
get the stems out of there just get
wisely and then I have already cut up
some jalapeno pepper ops felt a slight
I'll remember the heats in the seeds so
I'm gonna go easy on you i'm not gonna
add to my like it Donald in that case
it's more seats the better excellent
right we've got about a minute so let's
rock it here all right we crushed that
up because we've still got a third drink
oh yeah well the third ones ready to
rock or not just a classic margarita
throw that in there more lime juice yes
then when you shake a cocktail you gonna
snack it on top go ahead you're gonna
shake that up for me okay shake it don't
fake now now come on shake it don't fake
it it's mine that's it that's how you do
it how you been doing that for years all
right
and now we're gonna head and pour that
right into the glass clearly done
something wrong no there we go there you
go and okay I just gonna pour that
straight in well have you taste that
okay let's give it a shot itsjen
jalapeno garnish very very classy yeah
yeah oh that's terrific yeah a little
might improve take on the classic well I
think so I think so and this i mean you
can do all kinds things get a little
mezcal to that if you like use the
tequila or little tiny mezcal modifier
all right so this is the classic
margarita we've run out of time to try
it but we know how that tastes folks all
of these recipes from bland vant Brian
van Flandern check out at market makers
are at Erik schatzker they're coming to
you on the sink of the my O'Brien thank
you very much